hi this is the mushroom mini box kit to
grow your own mushrooms in it's the most
dangerous object in the office this
month take a jar filled with vermiculite
a syringe containing spores stick it
into the lid to inoculate the substrate
these are Oster mushrooms place the jar
in a safe place away from direct
sunlight
the three to five days germination has
begun
a few weeks after inoculation it's now
time to birth what is called the cake
it'll be a distinct mushroomy aroma
place the cake inside the mushroom kit
for the fruiting cycle in a couple weeks
you have fresh pickable mushrooms all in
all the process takes four to six weeks
from spore inoculation to fruiting
you